I'LL TELL YOU WHAT
SHE'S GONNA DO TO US.
SHE'S GONNA CUT OFF MY DICK
AND FEED IT TO ME.
I HAVE A VERY
CUT-OFFABLE DICK.
AND I'M HUNGRY.
- AS SOON AS SHE DICES
YOUR LITTLE DICK U--
YOUR DECENT-SIZED DICK UP...
- THANK YOU.
- THE GIRL WITH THE DRAGON
TATTOO IS GOING TO KILL US.
- HEY GUYS.
[guys screams]
- JEEZ...US.
- WOW.
ANNOUNCE YOURSELF
NEXT TIME.
- SORRY.
UH, SOME FRIEND OF YOURS
BROUGHT YOU A STEAK LUNCH.
I THOUGHT IT WAS SNAKE LUNCH
AT FIRST,
BUT THEN SHE CLARIFIED
IT'S A STEAK LUNCH.
AND I'M NOT JEALOUS, P.S.
[clears throat loudly]
- THANK YOU.
- LOOKS LIKE, UH,
DRAGON TATS
IS COMING AROUND.
- THANK YOU.
- SHE PROBABLY FORGOT
WE OWE HER MONEY.
- YEAH.
- STONERS, RIGHT?
- HERE'S A NOTE.
OH, COME ON.
"ENJOY THIS MEAL ON ME.
SINCERELY, YOU KNOW WHO."
GUYS.
- YOU KNOW WHO IT PROBABLY IS?
IT'S PROBABLY
THE DRAGON-TATTOOED GIRL.
- AH, BOY.
- YEAH.
- I FEEL LIKE
A SILLY GOOF, HUH?
WE WERE ALL WORRIED
ABOUT NOOOOO---
NO, NO!
JUDGE LANCE ITO!